okay we should start so thank you all
for coming so this is remarkably enough
week 11 of this lecture series and we're
very happy this this week to have Daniel
home from Eleven Madison Park boom
who will get to speak in a minute and he
will give a lecture called where as the
asset but before he does that you have
to put up with me so we have a fun game
here in science and cooking we have a
fun game and science and cooking we play
this sometimes it's a parlor game
we haven't marketed yet no one to my
knowledge has done it it's called guests
the food so would anyone like to guess
the food yes well peanut butter any
other guesses yes in the back chocolate
yes
bone marrow actually bone marrow is the
closest this is beef
okay so so guess the food here's another
one it's a good game actually
does anybody yes say again vegetable oil
that's very good it's olive oil okay
very good so I mean of course the way
that you play the game of guess the food
is that you all know that there are
major molecules of food there are faster
there are carbohydrates there are
proteins there's water which is not
listed on the food label and if you look
at those and you look at the percentages
of the various things you can sort of
guess the food so you guess the a lot of
the vegetable oil instead of olive oil
because was all fats or what do you
think it is but you know the question
that I want to raise is what else is
important for food that is what else is
important in a recipe other than this I
mean look if you have a if you have a
jar of water right the the number of
molecules per liter in that jar of water
is enormous there's no sort of you know
more than 10 to the 23 there's about 10
to the 25 molecules of water that's in a
liter of water it's a huge number but it
turns out that and this is the main
thing out the idea I want to leave you
with before I turn this over to Daniel
is that is that often times there are
ingredients in a recipe which are at
very very low concentrations but yet are
extremely important for taste and just
to demonstrate this here is a typical
recipe for a lemonade and the question
is is what makes it taste like lemonade
yes the acid very good that was in the
title of the lectures and where is the
acid
the acid is in the lemons okay very good
so in fact the acid that's in the
webbings is called citric acid here is a
picture of it and the citric acid is
this complicated formula its chemical
formula and the main point of it is that
an acid is something that more easily
loses protons to water so an acid
releases protons which are H pluses
which go into water so so even in water
there are protons that are in water in
the form of hydronium ions and the
concentration of them is one part in 10
to the 7 of the of the moles per liter
which is more than 110 million it's
actually more than that it's like one
over five hundred and fifty millionth of
the atoms that are of the molecules
there in water are these protons but yet
they're critically important for taste
this is what I want to tell you that
even though there are so few of them
they're critically important for taste
and when you see chef Daniel do magical
things with acids then in fact he's
adding so few protons that if all of you
in this room were water molecules there
wouldn't be one of you who is a proton
in the dish that he makes they're just
so few but yet they're critically
important for taste and you can control
them by by playing with things that chef
Daniel will play with and I was going to
turn it over to chef Daniel
Wow thank you Michael
how are you guys hey thank you so much
for coming thank you for having me here
it means a lot it's a great honor to be
part of this program and I'm excited to
talk about a little bit about myself my
story the story of Eleven Madison Park
and you know a few things that I've
learned along the way in the kitchen but
before I start I have a confession to
make
me I never finished high school in fact
I hated going to school I hated going to
classes and studying things I knew I
probably never going to use when I was
14 I left school to be a cook obviously
that was not a very popular decision
with my parents but it's been the best
thing I ever done the things that the
path of cooking has opened me to it's
been unbelievable the people I've met
along the way I've traveled the world
learned about different foods and
different cultures I learned languages
the opportunities just have been
unbelievable
eight years ago I came to this country
with two suitcases mostly full of chef's
clothes cookbooks some knives I had a
couple hundred dollars I did not speak
English
now I'm here speaking in front of you at
Harvard that's insane
this is one of the best schools in the
world maybe the best school in the world
this is the American dream when they
first asked me to speak here I wasn't
sure if I'm the right candidate because
I'm not a public speaker I'm not this is
totally out of my comfort zone I'm
nervous
standing up here I'm a cook the place
where I feel comfortable
is the kitchen but as I thought a little
bit more about the opportunity I knew I
knew that there definitely things I have
to share
it's amazing how food has changed over
the past few years now everyone in the
world wants to know about food chefs and
restaurants when I started 25 years ago
there was no food and science program at
Harvard or at any school there was no
food network they weren't all these TV
shows all these magazines for sure there
were no celebrity chefs back then it was
just about the craft of cooking I fell
in love with it because I love the
energy in the kitchen
I love to work with fresh ingredients I
love to work with my hands create
something with my hands cooking is very
tangible something my dad always used to
say he said it doesn't matter when
you're passionate about something how
big or small it is the only thing that
matters
is how much effort you're willing to put
towards that and that's what cooking has
been for me and that is what Eleven
Madison Park represents today I have
this clicker here in my hand
been holding it really awkwardly I don't
really I've never used one of those so I
just going to give it to Mike to put
something together like this or to do
anything great it always takes a team
and I want to say thank you to a few
people that help have helped a lot with
this I want to say thank you to Mike
pyres I want to say thank you to Connie
Chung both of them are chefs at a
restaurant and are in charge of all the
research and development I want to say
thank you to Aaron Ginsberg who is art
director for strategic development and
he has spent hours with me practicing
this
literally hours I want to say thank you
to Ally Bhusari who is a friend and the
scientist who helped so much with this
and made sure we have all the facts
straight I also want to say thank you to
my business partner will Ghaderi and my
best friend I want to say thank you to a
few things on one side I want to say
thank you to create a culture of
hospitality and service that has set new
standards in our industry because we can
talk about food and work our time in the
kitchen but if the hospitality and the
service sucks it all doesn't matter so
thank you for that in addition I want to
say thank you for supporting me teaching
me pushing me to do things I never
thought I could I also want to say thank
you to my girlfriend Cara and her mom
who are both here today because we can
have all the support professionally and
at work but you also need to support at
home so please give a hand of applause
to all
so let me give you a little context
about the restaurant Eleven Madison Park
is in the heart of Manhattan it's on
Madison Avenue and 24th Street it's in a
beautiful art deco building the building
is occupying an entire city block in
fact the building was supposed to become
the tallest building in the world when
it was built in 1928 but due to the
Great Depression the build was halted
but what we ended up with is this
incredible dining room 30 foot tall
ceilings huge windows overlooking
Madison Square Park one of the most
beautiful parks in New York you even can
see the Flatiron Building imagine this
dining room was supposed to be the lobby
of the tallest building in the world
there is no other restaurant with a
better view than ours it's such a New
York space such a New York room so it's
important that through the experience we
pay homage through our food and through
the delivery of the food to the place
we're in our inspiration come from
fishermen farmers artisans all around
New York when people what people don't
realize when they think about New York
all they think of is Manhattan and this
concrete jungle but we're on the
Atlantic coast which is one of the most
amazing waters for seafood also when you
drive just a half an hour north you
reach farmland for hours and hours and
miles and miles the Hudson Valley the
Finger Lakes have some of the most
amazing conditions for agriculture
because of its soil the surrounding
waters and it's amazing climate
but in addition what we have we have New
York City hundreds of years of history
immigrants from all over the world came
to settle this place they all brought
food traditions these traditions have
evolved and new traditions have been
created
eating at Eleven Madison Park is the
intersection I can hear my business
partner will laugh for true though it's
the intersection between on one side we
have these amazing ingredients the
amazing agriculture and on the other
side we have this rich history and
culture of New York the place that is
our home but that's not why I'm here
today I'm here to talk about acid and
acid in food where is the acid my staff
hears me say this more than they
probably care to remember but where is
the acid is really the central question
when we create a new dish
when seasoning food everyone talks about
salt
I believe acid is just as important
maybe more important than salt when I
grew up in Switzerland I was always
drawn to see acidic foods I love
Tomatoes I love citrus fruits I love
pickles my mom's cooking sauerkraut
roasted chicken with lemon and rosemary
she made a braised rabbit with olives
orange and pickled onions I never knew
exactly why I was drawn to these dishes
so much why they were my favorite but
looking back it makes sense because
there was presence of acid which gave it
balance and it highlighted the food at
the Eleven Madison Park why does this
matter so much well I think acid catches
your attention I think when you taste
acid it kind of wakes you up and it just
makes food better as it just makes food
better at Eleven Madison we serve
tasting menus 14 15 16 courses it's
important that all these dishes have
acid we use acid from so many different
sources but it keeps the guests excited
it keeps the meal lighter and it makes
the guests want more our food is
different than let's say traditional
French food where it relies heavily on
butter cream and fat until a few years
ago we never really thought too much
about your mouth of acid we're using but
then we started kind of digging into our
food and trying to understand or food a
little bit more and we realized that the
acid is the foundation of our cuisine
and as we dug even deeper we realized
that acid was doing so many other things
and these three things I want to tell
you today about number one acid effects
the flavoring food number two acid
affects the structure in food and number
three we use acid to preserve food let's
get into flavor
obviously flavor comes first it's the
most important to us we want the food to
be delicious when we add acid to food it
changes how you perceive the other basic
tastes it interacts with the saltiness
the sweetness we do mommy and with
bitter a great example for this and I'm
sure you've all seen it but sometimes
you get an espresso with a slice of
lemon that lemon is there to squeeze
lemon juice in the espresso what it does
you add sour to the bitter and
it makes you perceive the bitter as less
bitter thankfully coffee has gotten a
lot better over the years so you don't
see that that much anymore but that was
the reason why we also looked at some
manufactured foods coca-cola soy sauce
ketchup all these rely heavily on acid
for the same reason it bounces the sugar
the saltiness but here's something else
it also makes food more shelf have a
better shelf life these ingredients
sometimes sit on the shelf for two three
years really two three years and you
taste it and you still sort of feel like
that fresh
as it also affects the aroma in food and
that is really important for us in the
kitchen we play with this all the time
let's say we make a lemon sorbet let's
say we make a lemon sorbet just using
lemon juice that's like every lemon
sorbet that's out there it's good it's a
good lemon sorbet but let's say we also
introduce aroma to this lemon sorbet
and the way we do it the sugar that is
required to make that sorbet we take
sugar cubes and we rub it on the skin of
those lemons and then season the sorbet
with that so now we're also introducing
aroma and now when you taste that lemon
sorbet
you smell that lemon sorbet and it
elevates the flavor of that sorbet the
same thing happens when you peel a
grapefruit I'm sure you've all peeled
grapefruit before before you eat it when
you peel it the aromas the oils there on
your hands they hit your nose and by the
time you eat that grapefruit it tastes
unbelievable the best grapefruit you
ever had it tastes much better than a
grapefruit you would just get served on
a plate
that's been pre-sliced in cocktails we
use it a lot if you're at the bar and
you're ordering in Manhattan I don't
know if you're old enough everyone in
here but
if you have a Manhattan the bartender at
the very end of serving you that drink
adds a twist of orange that twist of
orange that aroma hits your nose it
elevates the flavor of that drink all
these things happen because your brain
is making a connection between what it
tastes and what it smells it elevates
the experience it's like going from
black and white to color we have some
backs here for you and I'm sorry Michael
we you know we weren't quite as prepared
as I wanted to but we disturbed your
talk a little bit with bringing in these
facts but here you have it
please grabbing these backs there are
two small bottles I want you to just
take out the two small bottles
okay and now put the backpack down we're
going to taste these
I would like to taste these as well no
thank you
in these two bottles we have soda we've
made a lot of different sodas over the
years celery soda
cherry soda coffee soda strawberry soda
but for here for you today we have maple
soda I want to taste the first one
without the sticker on it
it definitely tastes like maple syrup
but it tastes really sweet also
in fact it's good but I wouldn't really
want to drink this soda it's too sweet
it's not balanced let's taste the other
one
and it's pretty impressive
our team filled all these small bottles
this afternoon and even I don't know
yeah
even more impressive is that they're
still cold let's taste this one these
sodas are made exactly the same way it's
the same recipe there's one change and
this soda for me tastes a lot less sweet
a lot more balanced a lot more delicious
kind of like what do you want soda to be
we add it in this case apple cider
vinegar to balance this out so this is
an example I wanted to give you because
it kind of is it kind of is a strong
example and the soda goes from really
not really drinkable to delicious in
food it's not always this extreme it can
be much more subtle but it can elevate
the right amount of acid can elevate the
experience of a dish let's talk about
our first dish here this dish is the
seafood boil it's inspired by seafood
boil you would have out by the water
on the ocean this seafood is extremely
fresh there's prawns lobster clams
it's amazing seafood you could just
steam that and eat it and it will be
delicious but what we do we cook it in a
broth of lemon beer and tomato we then
bring it out to the dining room and we
put a big wooden board right in the
middle of the table we take that seafood
and we dump it right onto that board
we're asking our guests
to eat this dish with their hands but
before they do we're asking them to
squeeze some fresh lemon over that
seafood so now we're introducing aroma
to already the acid that we introduced
during cooking it elevates that seafood
it makes it a better dish our next dish
is a roasted duck this dish is on the
money all the time these are these
amazing ducks we get up from the Finger
Lakes we're really proud of the product
and the preparation it's glazed with
honey on this picture we serve it with
rutabaga whipped honey some bee pollen
and then a sauce that is mazed
we caramelize sugar duk-soo and there's
four acids in the sauce we have lemon
juice lime juice orange juice and
vinegar the duck is gamy meaty fatty and
rich now we're also adding sugar in the
form of the honey and in the sauce so
it's really really important that we're
playing with a lot of assets and it's
sort of like the sensation of sweet and
sour here we have oysters we get these
oysters from Long Island
they're two hours away from a restaurant
we get them every day and they're as
fresh as the oyster can be you could
just shuck them and eat them right out
of the shell and it will be delicious
these oysters are served with champagne
grapes let's know that we make with
Concord grape juice and red wine vinegar
and we also have sorrow
a lot of the guests come up to me and
say wow these are the freshest oysters I
ever had or they come to me and say wow
the combination of oysters and grapes is
unbelievable and that's cool but what
they're really responding to is the high
amount of acid that is in the snow and
it makes them believe they've had
oysters this fresh before but the high
amount of acid makes them believe that
these are the freshest oysters they ever
had it's the same thing that we talked
about manufactured foods they add acid
to make shitty food taste better but if
we use that and we use the best
ingredients that we can get our hands on
and we're adding acid in the right
amount we can make a great product into
an unbelievable product here we have the
second one structure just like we did
with the spoon as it changes the
structure in food we took this spoon we
bent it it changes the function of this
spoon here we have milk we're adding
acid we're changing the structure of the
molecules in that milk and it turns it
into curd this is the basics of cheese
making I want to show you this in one of
our dishes where we use that to our
advantage here all the way on the left
side you see a pot with milk and there's
some hay in it and the hay is there to
flavor the milk
and there's also lemon juice in that
milk now we're bringing that milk up to
temperature and you can see how it
starts to separate then we're straining
it so now we have the curd on one side
and the way on the other side the way
usually is a bi-product and it gets
thrown out but what I love about this
dish is how we bring these two
ingredients back together we're making
an yogi we're taking the curd and we
roll it in semolina we're taking the way
and make it into a really flavorful
broth we surf the gnocchi with some
beautiful greens and we pour the broth
tableside this is a dish of scallops and
it's a raw scallop just marinated we get
these amazing scallops we open them
fresh out of the shell they're still
alive we marinate them with green apple
juice so the scallop firms up it changes
the structure in those scallops and
Michael was just flying through this
thing but he touched on ceviche but it's
the same thing that happens with ceviche
the lemon lime or pineapple juice it
changes the structure in that seafood
and it gives it a different texture the
apple juice double use to marinate the
scallop is also affected by that we're
adding citric ask Orbach acid to this
apple juice and we use it because it's
close to flavor neutral but yes the
addition of ascorbic acid keeps the
apple juice from turning brown
this is the same thing that happens when
you make a guacamole you add lemon to
that avocado so it doesn't turn brown
the same thing can happen with mushrooms
or when you peel artichokes here we have
egg yolks I love eggs X is probably one
of the most versatile ingredients that
we work with and all the way on the left
side the top part is a raw egg yolk on
the bottom we open it up so we show you
the consistency egg yolks are extremely
creamy but we try to find a way how can
we make it even creamier in the middle
we took the egg yolk on the top and we
marinated it in white balsamic vinegar
for two days on the bottom in the middle
we open it up to show you the change in
consistency that egg yolk got thicker
creamier and then we took it even
further all the way on the right is an
egg yolk that's been sitting in white
balsamic vinegar for seven days and you
can see on the bottom picture all the
way on the right that now the egg yolk
is barely liquid anymore it's gotten a
lot firmer and that's pretty cool here
this is an experiment that we did just
for today this is red cabbage and red
cabbage is functioning like a natural pH
meter we added acids and we added
alkaline and just based on those colors
you can see the change in pH
all the way on the left we added white
wine vinegar the most acidic things we
added of all of them then we added white
wine the third one we actually just
added cabbage juice as being the neutral
one and then we're adding all Co lines
which the blue one is baking soda then
we added lye and then we added bleach
obviously don't want to eat this but
this is really cool
just by the change of pH the color
changes and these are bright colors
dramatically this happens with other
things too for example a blueberry
muffin you've at all had blueberry
muffins when you look at a blueberry
muffin
sometimes you see around the blueberry a
small circle of green the blueberry is
starting to turn green this happens
because the baking soda is interacting
with the acid in the blueberries when
you see that it's usually not a good
sign it's usually it's not the best
blueberry muffin you ever had because it
means there's too much baking soda in it
but that's what happens and the same
thing happens right now you walk outside
on the streets and you see all the
leaves changing on the trees there's
other things that go on there but one of
the biggest reasons that these leaves
are changing color is because the pH
level in these leaves is changing
preservation acid is involved in two
types of preservations on one side we
have pickling and on the other side we
have fermentation if you take this
cucumber here if you just let it sit
that bacteria will grow and I know the
picture of these bacteria is kind of
ridiculous but
somehow I wanted to make this point if
you let this cucumber sit these
bacterias will grow it will destroy the
cucumber or it will destroy you in the
presence of acid bad bacteria dies come
on in pickling we simply add acid in
form of vinegar in fermentation acid is
naturally produced which will keep the
bad bacteria from growth we use this all
the time here on this picture we have
pickled purple eggplants the one on the
right is just a raw slice the one on the
left is been pickled what's really cool
here too is because of the eggplants
purple skin it penetrates that color
throughout and it looks really beautiful
here we have pickled plums sometimes we
use the sous-vide method for pickling
pickling under pressure speeds out the
process of pickling here we have
fermented mustard greens we simply let
these mustard greens ferment by adding
salt water onions and ginger and again
through the fermentation process acid is
produced and it will keep bad bacteria
from growing here we have a foie gras
dish that we serve in a restaurant
it's a foie gras dish with sunchokes I
love this dish and it's a dish that we
serve during the winter months and I
love this dish so much because
preservation allows us here to use angry
ian's that are out of season on this
dish we have fermented mustard greens
and they're a little hard to see and I
think we could have picked maybe a
better picture but I promise you there
there
we have pickled sunchokes and we have a
relish of onions and mustard seeds
I love how preservation is helping us in
this dish we're using ingredients
they're out of season but in addition
also preservation is bringing acid to
the dish which helps balance the flavor
of that rich and creamy foie gras we
could talk about this an entire lecture
and more it's a really complex topic
fermentation preservation and I know a
week from today Jody Adams will give an
entire class on fermentation let's get
back to our original question where is
the acid we use many different assets
from all kinds of places
so let's look into our pantry this is a
picture of our dry storage we have
bottled vinegars that we buy from
balsamic vinegars Banyuls vinegar sherry
vinegars red wine vinegars we have all
kinds of vinegar powders that we're
using malic acid powders lactic acid
powders citric acid powders we're also
making our own vinegar we have a vinegar
machine and then we age the vinegar in
barrels making our own vinegar allows us
to be very specific to our dishes
in our walk-in we have all the fresh
dairy that brings us the lactic acid
from creme fraiche yogurt cream and milk
and then of course we have all the
fruits citrus fruits apples pineapples
they give us acid we're using a pH meter
at the restaurant and we're using it as
a measure to give us more consistency
more accuracy we're using it in a way we
use a scale or in a way we measure
temperature I want to talk a little bit
about some of the pH levels that we
we've learned about and I want to start
with water and remember I'm sure you
probably all know this but I want to
remember you remind you that the lower
the number in pH the higher the acidity
so we took our still water and this is
the water we serve with our meal we took
still water and we measured it at seven
point five seven is neutral so it's very
close to neutral then we measured our
sparkling water and our sparkling water
is highly acidic and then we even asked
ourselves is it just the bubbles or when
it goes flat will the acidity remain and
it does what's cool about here is that
we actually learned that co2 is a source
of acid so we can add co2 to anything
and the acidity in that will increase
but then there's something else when you
go have dinner
the most simple question in the
beginning of your meal do you want still
or sparkling water
this question is not that simple anymore
because it changes the experience of
your meal dramatically we also looked at
the manufactured foods that we talked
earlier and we measured those they're
highly acidic all of them but the most
surprising here was Coca Cola everyone
in the world drinks Coca Cola
everyone loves coca-cola coca-cola is
more acidic than red wine vinegar just
imagine that isn't that crazy you eat
that with your meal it's more acidic
than red wine vinegar
that's unbelievable and when you drink
coca-cola you never think of it as being
acidic and that is why and that's
because there's so much sugar to balance
all that acid and makes it a beverage
that everyone loves I talked about this
dish earlier our duck dish and I told
you the sensation of sweet and sour and
how crucial the sauce is the perfect
level in this sauce of pH is 4.6 so I
wanted to see if we take our cooks or
line cooks and we have them make the
sauce over a period of three weeks make
it blindly without a pH meter just by
taste and this is what they came in in
those ranges they came in between 4.3
and 4.9 it's pretty close don't you
think it's really close and it's just by
taste so then I wanted to see okay let's
take our more experienced cooks our sous
chefs and let's have them do the same
thing and see if they could get it
closer and thankfully they did but hey
just to be clear when I make this sauce
but so that's great we have pH levels
and it helps us to make it more accurate
and it's a great tool but even if that
sauce has the perfect pH level it
doesn't mean the sauce is delicious
it can taste totally off and I think
that is where the magic of cooking comes
in we can have all these scientific
tools but it will never replace the
palate the palate or the talent of the
chefs who are in the kitchen talk about
wine
and and this is this is based on the
people I worked with on this you might
drink different wines at Harbor but wine
we can't talk about acid and not
mentioning wine wine is such a big part
of a restaurant of a dining experience
and acid in wine is so so so important
we have the wines on the left that we
pair with our food and then we have the
wines that you might drink in college
and we measured those and for our
pairing remember our food is highly
acidic so what we need we need a wine to
be a perfect pairing to pair food you
need a wine that is just as acidic maybe
even more acidic and what that does is
it lets you know it lets the flavor of
the wine come true it lets the wine be
wine and not be overpowered by the food
although the wines on the right that was
a surprise to us because these wine
they're highly acidic when we drink
these wines we think of them as
extremely sweet very high in alcohol and
very low in acidity so we were surprised
to see these numbers so again the pH
level is not you can't taste the pH in
these wines of lesser quality there is
acid added artificially to balance all
that sweetness and that sugar
and that's why when you drink cheap wine
you have a way worse hangover then when
you drink good quality one there is a
common theme manufactured foods adds
acid to make bad food taste better the
wine industry takes this really sweet
high alcoholic bad grape juice they add
acid and they can sell it if we take
that knowledge and we add it to the best
ingredients we have and we use it
carefully we can make food from great to
unbelievable it affects all levels of
food on every level as it changes and
highlights the ingredients so I've been
talking a lot but I want to talk about
one more dish and this dish I'm really
excited about this is a dish that we
serve at the restaurant we've been
serving it for a long time it's a dish
that a lot of people talk about and
people really love it's a dish of
character tar this is this dish is
inspired by a classic New York steak
tartare and we worked on this idea for a
while this is what we came up with also
I think it's what we talked about
earlier the intersection between great
ingredients and the history of New York
I think it's demonstrated in this dish
really well we have these amazing
carrots from upstate New York from the
Hudson Valley we get it from a farm his
name is Alex Pathan
this guy has been growing carrots for
the last 40 years he grows about 40
different types of carrots these are the
best carrots I have ever tasted we
wanted to make them the star of this
dish and the way we serve it we bring
out this meat grinder into the dining
room and we clamp it on to the table at
this point the guests don't really know
what to expect they expect to be meat
but then we come out with these amazing
carrots and in this dish we demonstrate
all three things that we talked about
today in this dish acid affects the
flavoring food in this dish acid affects
the structure in the food and also we're
using acid to preserve food so the cook
comes out and grinds these carrots
tableside into that board and on that
palette of ingredients we ask our guests
to be their own chefs and add these
ingredients to their liking and mix it
together we have a marinated egg yolk
what we talked about earlier we have
pickled mustard seeds we have compressed
apples we have a mustard of apple and we
have a carrot vinaigrette and now in
your back there's a char with this dish
already mixed
we also have a little bag of some rye
crackers you can dip them in I would
love to bring like 300 meat grinders and
make that dish for you but I couldn't so
this is already mixed and please taste
it
acid is so important in this dish you
can you can taste it and acid in a way
it's such a simple thing adding acid but
then also acid to so many complicated
things that we didn't know and we simply
took for granted there is one more thing
in that back for you and everyone anyone
who leaves a restaurant at Eleven
Madison leaves with a jar of granola the
granola has nothing to do with acid but
we're also in the hospitality business
and we just wanted you to have a
delicious breakfast
thank you guys